breaking ideas idee che rompono e dalle
5 di questo pomeriggio che queste idee
rompono
ma che cosa rompono questa idea ce lo
siamo chiesto e io un'ipotesi cielo le
scatole le scatole sono definizioni
nella vita noi abbiamo bisogno di
definizioni gli schemi di stereotipi
perché ne abbiamo bisogno per il mondo è
molto complesso e quando ci troviamo
davanti a cose che non sappiamo
interpretare aumenta il nostro livello
di stress
si è parlato oggi molto di cervello e si
è parlato molto del fatto che il
cervello si è voluto per rispondere a
esigenze che avevamo milioni di anni fa
migliori da anni fa lo stress
era un grande problema perché molto
spesso era generato da cose sconosciute
ed erano pericoli di morte
quindi il nostro cervello si è voluto
per gestire lo stress più velocemente
possibile
quando non abbiamo le scatole quando non
abbiamo gli schemi gli stereotipi
succede che il segnale del pericolo
dell'ignoto prende una cosiddetta via
bassa e va direttamente su un pezzetto
del nostro cervello che si chiama
amigdala che un pezzetto primitivo che è
velocissimo nel gestirlo e nel reagire
ma lanig d'ala
nel fare questo certe volte ci salva la
vita molto più spesso soprattutto oggi
commette degli errori prende il
controllo di tutto il nostro cervello ci
fa sbagliare e ci fa sprecare risorse lo
spreco di risorse non è una buona cosa
per il nostro cervello quando abbiamo
delle scatole quando abbiamo delle
definizioni questo ci consente di
prendere la via lunga quindi le
informazioni arrivano alla corteccia
prefrontale che il cosiddetto boss buono
della nostra testa è quello che è capace
di gestire l'informazione e farci
ragionare e farci dare la risposta
migliore quindi le scatole sono delle
strategie le strategie che la nostra
mente usa per renderla realtà più
semplice e per non dover fare tutte le
volte la fatica di capire che cosa
abbiamo davanti di decidere e di
scegliere
quindi possiamo dire che le scatole e
semplificano creano dei territori comuni
in cui noi ci capiamo gli uni con gli
altri
ma anche ci proteggono ci fanno sentire
protetti ci fanno intuire e prevedere il
comportamento degli altri e in questo
sono molto importante alla sopravvivenza
in questo mondo però sempre di più le
condizioni intorno a noi cambiano
velocemente se le condizioni cambiano e
le scatole restano uguali succede che le
scatole e quei muri che erano nati per
proteggerci diventano delle barriere e
ostruiscono il nostro pensiero
ostruiscono la nostra immaginazione sono
delle vere e proprie gabbie il grosso
problema delle gabbie e che noi non ce
ne accorgiamo che ce l'abbiamo nella
testa quindi ce l'abbiamo lì e non ci
accorgiamo di averle e se non sappiamo
di averle molto difficile romperle per
questo facciamo un the licks su chi le
rotte come si fa oggi vi devo spiegare
come romperle queste scatole
come si fa a rompere queste scatole come
si fa ad accorgersi che qualche
stereotipo è diventato inabilitante vi
darò tre veloci metodi per farlo 1 e
quantitativo e due sono più qualitativi
il primo proprio un metodo statistico
diciamo che adesso qui vi ho messo un
ipotesi statistica un po a caso ma
fondamentalmente ogni regola
tra le sue eccezioni quando il numero di
eccezioni che in questo caso chiameremo
anomalie cioè quei casi che non
rientrano nello stereotipo diventa
statisticamente rilevante e qui ho messo
un 30 per cento ma può valere anche un
numero piu basso
ecco in quel caso siamo probabilmente di
fronte ad una gabbia due elementi
qualitativi
quando c'è una gabbia nel nostro
cervello quando viviamo dentro una
gabbia aumenta la fatica c'è una
sensazione di fatica che non si riesce a
spiegare fare quella cosa genera fatica
spreco di risorse
il terzo elemento è un classico effetto
collaterale dello stereotipo
inabilitante e l'infelicità
molto spesso quando si vive in questi
stereotipi non si è felici
detto questo adesso vi devo spiegare
ovviamente no un paio di esempi un paio
di esempi perché sono anticipate ci sono
grandi cose piccole cose sullo
stereotipo me le faccio due esempi che
diciamo possono toccare un po la vita di
tutti quanti ecco noi cresciamo leggendo
favole che ci dicono che l'amore se è
vero dura per sempre ma è così c'è
l'amore per essere vero deve durare per
sempre
quarant'anni fa i miei genitori si sono
separati 40 anni fa la legge sul
divorzio era appena passata e separarsi
alla dura era un grosso stigma la
separazione non eravamo abituati
quarant'anni dopo la metà dei matrimoni
finisce in separazione o divorzio
eppure quello stigma e ancora tutto qua
c'è ancora la sensazione che un
matrimonio debba durare per sempre
e questo qual è il problema di questa
cosa il problema è che 160.000 copie
solo nel 2011 si sono separate e oltre
alla fatica del cambiamento che comunque
cioè hanno dovuto anche addossarsi uno
stigma c'è la sensazione e con loro 160
mila bambini la sensazione che la loro
famiglia fosse meno ok delle altre che
ci fosse una norma e che la loro
famiglia fosse diventata disfunzionale
questa è una scatola che forse non
funziona più facciamo veniamo a vedere
una scatola che riguarda sempre il
rapporto di coppia ma nel mondo
lavorativo c'è un rapporto lavorativo
che sembra non funzionare
che è quello tra donne e lavoro come
faccio a dirvi che non funziona anche
qui depositare di dati statistici
se andiamo a vedere come va
l'occupazione femminile quella riga in
basso quella nera quella piatta piatta e
l'occupazione femminile in italia che
non riesce a sforare quota 50 per cento
in italia a meno di una donna su due
lavora ed è così da anni e non sembra
migliorare
quali sono gli stereotipi in questo caso
ce ne sono diversi al lavoro per esempio
il fatto che la maternità possa essere
una causa di indebolimento lavorativo
per esempio l'idea che il lavoro debba
essere misurato per quantità quando
ormai si lavora in termini di conoscenza
degli stereotipi ce n'è veramente tanti
e siamo di fronte a una situazione di
difficoltà e di fatica
allora adesso andiamo a vedere come
aprire queste gabbie perché si possano
e dobbiamo farlo tutti non solo i dodici
speaker che hanno parlato prima di me
come aprire le gabbie vedere uno dei
metodi dicevo il modo principale è far
parlare l'anomalia ogni anomalia ha una
storia da raccontare
se devo ad ascoltare la storia
dell'anomalia cioè di chi non si ritrova
in quella gabbia scopriremo che esiste
un altro schema nuovo molto più
resiliente perché molto più pronto a
cambiare e che funziona per esempio
prendiamo una signora che ha sempre
detto cose molto intelligenti e questo è
un primo metodo che vi voglio spiegare
cambiare i modelli vice rita levi
montalcini
ma perché noi donne entrando nel mondo
del lavoro vogliamo essere uguali agli
uomini se siamo diverse perché vogliamo
scimmiottare un modello che non è il
nostro perché non possiamo creare il
nostro modello quindi creare nuovi
modelli è un modo per aprire le gabbie
questo vuol dire che noi prendiamo lo
stigma della maternità cioè quella fase
della vita in cui si è convinti che
lavorativamente parlando si perdano
colpi e convinciamo e della verità è
scientificamente provato che le
competenze che si sviluppano in quella
fase della vita sono competenze che ti
rendano più forte sul lavoro
abbiamo ribaltato un vecchio modello e
funziona
andiamo a sentire un altro signore che a
me sta molto simpatico che ce l'abbiamo
tatuato sulle nostre pareti in ufficio
che dice che c'è un altro modo per
uscire dagli stereotipi inabilitanti c'è
un altro modo preso in lega b ed è usare
l'immaginazione e qui veramente via
libera la fantasia
ve ne dico due una che è proprio folle
però a me piace per esempio perché il
matrimonio deve essere per sempre e se
diventasse un contratto a tempo
determinato che dura cinque anni ed è
rinnovabile non avremo tutti un po
diversamente come sarebbe la situazione
verso il quarto anno quando bisogna
rinegoziare tutte tutte le condizioni
non sarebbero più romantici gli uomini
sapendo che dopo cinque anni ne possiamo
tagliare senza tanti casini come
l'avrebbero i figli la separazione se
sapessero che normale ma tra l'anno papà
mamma ridiscutono poi vediamo
eventualmente arriva un altro c'è la
fatica diminuisce parecchio perché non
farlo se uno su due non è per sé
sempre un'altra cosa che volevo fare
perché ho ancora un po di tempo
un altro esempio di come si può
distruggere uno stereotipo è provare a
parlare di una cosa di cui di solito si
parla male vedendo negli aspetti
positivi e c'è una giornalista
dell'huffington post per esempio che ha
scritto un articolo
raccontando tutti gli aspetti positivi
di chi si separa ve ne leggo solo un
paio chi si separa alla mente aperta e
capace di vedere oltre la tipica
fantasia dell'amore che dura per sempre
e crede che non dobbiamo tutti per forza
rientrare nello stesso stampino è aperto
a un'intera vita di possibilità che
supera l'idea di un esistenza in cui
solo la morte può separarci da qualcuno
che non amiamo conosciamo o rispettiamo
abbastanza chi si separa creativo deve
affrontare molte nuove sfide come un
nuovo tenore di vita nuovi modi di
comunicare con l'ex 9 routine tutto da
ripensare fuori dalla scatola in modo
creativo per dare vita non ho idea di
famiglia chi si separa per esempio ci
avete mai pensato tiene moltissimo le
relazioni si si avete sentito bene
decidere di separarsi non vuol dire
cancellare un rapporto potete farlo
evolvere in qualcosa di diverso come un
rapporto tra genitori che collaborano e
magari col tempo diventano anche amici
perché no
insomma dice questa giornalista le
persone separate sono fantastiche no lo
so non possiamo attribuire
automaticamente questa lista di
caratteristiche a tutti separati ma non
possiamo neanche attribuiti tutte le
caratteristiche negative che oggi lo
stigma della separazione si porta dietro
a me personalmente questi assunti fanno
stare meglio e quindi mi ritengo ecco un
po più di notizie così buone notizie non
ci aiuterebbero a rompere un po di
stereotipi
l'ultima cosa che vi lascio prima di un
paio di frasi finali e una lista di
pensieri quotidiani che potete usare per
vedere se ci sono le gabbie e per
aprirle sono molto molto semplice sono
cose che puoi mente già fate per esempio
facciamoci domande ti devo c perché
facciamo una cosa in quel modo
se non ci convince chiediamo solo perché
lo stiamo facendo
ricordiamoci perché lo facciamo
guardiamoci intorno
guardiamoci intorno e guardiamo se anche
dentro qualche volta guardiamo lontano
alzare lo sguardo oggi si è detto tante
volte cosa cambia nella tua vita quando
improvvisamente guardi lontano cosa vedi
mettiamo in discussione tutti gli schemi
e questo lo abbiamo detto le regole le
definizioni cambiamo le parole
avete visto che effetto fa semplicemente
leggere un articolo un po diverso
proviamo a cambiare le parole sono
importanti sono tutt'oggi le parole
usiamo nel modo giusto le parole possono
essere muri ma possono anche essere
finestre dipende da come sono usate
parliamo di felicità parliamone di
felicità soprattutto pensiamo alla
felicità e facciamo tutto questo senza
paura senza paura di sbagliare noi siamo
nel paese in cui si ha paura di
sbagliare se ha paura di cambiare
si ha paura di essere diversi vanno
invece il bello della vita nella
diversità per chiudere due frasi che a
me piacciono tantissimo una dice smetti
di definirti concedi di tutte le
possibilità di essere cambia strada ogni
volta che lo senti necessario questo
vorrei recuperare il senso della
possibilità che quello che ti permette
di vedere le cose come sono
immaginare come potrebbero essere e fare
quel pezzo di strada da come sono come
potrebbero essere poi farlo intorno a te
lo puoi farlo su te stesso puoi decidere
che tu puoi cambiare anche negli ultimi
due anni anzi vi devo dire devo dire
anche a matteo per fortuna non c'è
un'età limite in cui c'è un'età massima
in cui si possono avere idee in cui si
può cambiare la propria vita e io ho 42
anni in realtà la mia vita l'ho cambiata
radicalmente negli ultimi due anni credo
che questo sia una buona notizia per
molti di noi sono due anni che metto in
discussione tutto perché poi quando
cominci ad aprire le gabbie non finisce
più
e sono due anni quindi che qualche volta
mi domando anche se sto facendo bene se
quello che faccio giusto se ho paura
allora è la mia mente va dal mio cuore e
chiede se ha paura è poi tornato e mi
dice ma un po di paura c'è però non è un
motivo sufficiente per restare nella
strada già tracciata
io sono libera ad immaginare e di
tracciare una nuova strada davanti a me
lo sto facendo
e voglio continuare a farlo grazie